for today's classic interview we're
going back to when I spoke to Janet
Heimlich nearly four years ago she's the
author of a book about mistreating
children based on religion she told me
about these horrible horrible practices
of child abuse in the name of religion
since her interview there's actually
been quite a bit that has happened
including an Oregon around this issue
and we're gonna go back and listen to
really the insane stories that she told
us nearly four years ago we've spoken
anecdotally on the show about these
instances of children being abused or
not receiving medical treatment
specifically because of religious
reasons and today to talk about this
issue and more is the author of the book
breaking their will shedding light on
religious child maltreatment Janet
Heimlich so Janet you'd say in the book
that this problem is far more widespread
than the few anecdotal cases I've talked
about on my show how widespread is this
it's a great question
I wish there was some sort of tracking
of these cases it's only been done with
narrow studies and and we really don't
have a good handle on numbers but what
we often find out is there's a child
that's been harmed after death and then
it makes the headlines and we all are
familiar with say a child who is
medically neglected due to religious
beliefs about faith healing and so they
die from things like diabetes or
infections and things like that how are
you here about a child that's beaten to
death by a parent or a member of our or
a neighbor or somebody like that who are
part of a church that believes that the
Bible says you should you should use the
rod and and use corporal punishment on
children or we hear about these you know
pervasive problems of sexual abuse among
clergy so we're really just kind of
trying to you know track track what
what's at the very top level what rises
to the surface and and makes headlines
and in newspapers and online
and so forth what we have to appreciate
is that for every child who we read
about who was through horrific suffering
there there has got to be untold number
of kids that are are harmed but don't
make headlines right I mean because part
of this is the is by its nature the type
of thing that kids are not going to
speak out about so we can only imagine
that for every one we hear about who
knows how many there are hundreds maybe
thousands that were not hearing about so
I kind of think that there are three
three areas here and you tell me if you
agree there is number one
you alluded to the sexual abuse
component which on this program we
particularly cover it visa vie the
Catholic Church but certainly it exists
across a number of religions then
there's the physical abuse which we've
talked about and there there were Act
there are actually some groups which
maybe you can speak to which have
manuals and guides which actually
dictate the physical punishment for
children and the number three is the
medical neglect which is choosing not to
obtain medical services for a child
either through the idea that prayer will
heal or through the idea that those
treatments go against God's will now of
the three which is the newest in other
words some elements of these I assume
have been around for a really long time
which of these are seeing the biggest
uprising lately well I want to first say
that you're missing one huge area which
i think is the most pervasive and that
is psychological and emotional neglect
entities often times we don't hear about
those cases even a religion is not
involved because they're next to
impossible to prove right it's hard to
occupy absolutely absolutely what you
you actually don't and in terms of
finding that someone a child has been
psychologically harmed it actually is
defined by the the harm itself the the
words that are used for example such as
you're a sinner and you're going to hell
or that kind of thing it's it actually
is not defined by proven results say you
know later on in life but I can almost
guarantee you at whenever you have a
case a religious child maltreatment that
involves sexual abuse physical abuse or
medical neglect you will you will have
psychological abuse for neglect as well
sure in fact the question of is one of
these something that we're seeing a
particularly drastic rise in lately no I
I wouldn't say that we are seeing
changes in the in the rate of these
things only because we're not able to
really track them I mean for example
when child protective services comes in
and interviews a family they're not
looking to see whether or not the
motivation behind the abuse or neglect
is a religious or spiritual
when someone is pulled over to the side
of the road by by a police officer and
they're given a ticket for speeding that
police officer will know whether or not
it's alcohol-related but we don't have
that same kind of tracking when it comes
to child abuse cases no other we did
have a story last week where a woman got
pulled over and actually said God was
telling her to go 100 miles per hour but
that seems got a little bit of an
isolated case now one thing people may
notice when they read the book and you
address this in the introduction is that
police officer doesn't have like they
they have a ready application with check
boxes and they have to know whether or
not it's a write it or not so I just
wanted to that's some I think we should
do in in terms of chocolate egg and
services but go ahead with your question
yeah well my question was going to be I
know that one of the criticisms will be
that hey you're focusing on Christianity
which of course Bill O'Reilly said a few
days ago is a philosophy and not a
religion but putting that aside for a
second that you focus on Christianity
you also talk about Judaism and Islam
but but there's going to be this claim
that hey are you focusing on
Christianity because it's the worst
offender or are you personally just
choosing to focus on that address that a
little bit sure without a doubt the
majority of cases that I talk about in
my book happen
to be christian-based that is simply
because my book focuses on American
crimes and far more people far more
religious people in this country
Christian than any other faith so that's
simply the way that numbers fall out if
I were to do this same book say in the
Middle East I'm sure you would have way
more problems that are in an Islamic
communities etc what what determines
where you have more problems than I was
not nothing to do with what God people
worship or what religious texts they're
reading it has to do with the
authoritarian nature of the culture the
child is being raised in so as such that
I'm glad you use the term authoritarian
because we've been on the program
talking for a while about traits that
seem to be exhibited in parenting that
leads to people growing up and being
politically conservative and traits in
parenting that lead to children being
liberal and the number one trait that
leads to conservative adults is when
they are children the parents have a
more authoritarian parenting technique
and tend to use more physical punishment
how do you think that that ties in to
the issues you talk about in the book
it's an interesting question they're
having psychological studies done on
individuals to determine what kind of a
follower are they are they more of an
authoritarian follower versus one who is
more liberal and and these studies have
shown that what what are called
authoritarian for followers meaning
people who are very conservative in
their beliefs very conventional in their
beliefs who are Pro punishment in their
beliefs they tend to be more on the
authoritarian scale which means that
they are much more likely to recognize
an authority figure and and and follow
that authority figure as well as fight
against those that they deemed to be
opposing that authority figure
I do talk a little bit about this
studies in my book because what they
have determined is that these very
conservative very Pro punishing people
often offer religious fundamentalists
interesting well there's plenty more in
the book that we haven't talked about I
encourage people to check it out it is
of course breaking their will shedding
light on religious child maltreatment
we've been speaking with the author
Janet Heimlich thank you so much for
talking to us today I think this is
although it's a very sad topic to have
to discuss the book is fascinating thank
you so much thanks alright we'll take a
break and we'll be back with plenty more
after this stay tuned